okay i'm not going to start from the top
because i think that was all just
introductory stuff right am i there now
do i exist i'm not a vampire anymore
hooray
okay
um
right i've got a neural network it has
the task of helping out the human
cytologists in identifying positive
cases of cervical cancer okay that makes
sense
describe the source of data for the
neural network
and the role of training in the
effectiveness of this system okay so
this question had two parts to it two
sort of subsections to get the three
marks the first part the source of data
just the one mark for that and that was
quite well done the second part
the role of training and the
effectiveness of this system we didn't
do so well on okay so let's try and
break that down
so this is um this is part a okay so
sources of data
now there are two main sources of data
that we need to supply to this neural
network to um to train it to get it to
understand and be able to recognize
these patterns someone help me out you
guys do quite well in this right what
are the two sources of data or two
pieces of data i guess
previous record okay thank you previous
records right so the slides the slides
that represent actual people
and their scans and that kind of thing
and what their cells look like okay so
great you've got a whole bunch of
patients and um the scans they've
already had and you take the pictures
here are the slides you supply that to
the neural network
but that's not all you need to give it
what else are we going to need to
provide to this neural network so i can
actually recognize what's cancer and
what's not
yeah that's right so
if you don't know
uh if you don't tell the artificial
neural network which ones are positive
and which ones are negative it's not
it's going to have all this data and not
know what to do with it okay so these
are the sources of data right you've got
to supply it that's fine okay now the
role of training
now please take some good notes on this
because your answers were not so great
so they need a little work okay i was
looking for you to mention three
particular things that talked about you
know what makes training work okay um
and in some ways because this is an
artificial neural network this is the
way our brains work okay even if you
didn't pay that much attention to the
decision support systems you could to
some measure sort of guess these but um
we did really badly on it okay so three
things number one
you just want a lot of data okay so you
want a sheer quantity
of
the previous records the slides right
the more you've got the more hundreds
and thousands and tens of thousands of
results you've got the more reliable
you'll be able to recognize these okay
but you don't just want lots of data
what kinds of data do you want
let's think back to one of the more
famous kinds of artificial networks
we've looked at under studying this
topic right um you remember
uh deep blue what was deep blue does
anyone remember what it was
it was an ibm computer that was designed
to play chess right now um and it was
famous because it beat gary kasparov who
was the world number one at the time
okay
now if you're trying to train a computer
to play chess okay imagine it just
played a single person all the time even
if they were very good at chess okay
suppose it was me once upon a time i
always go to chess in primary school i
have like trophies and stuff and then i
came to roost and everyone played chess
anyway um now imagine if i sat down with
it and played
you know tens of thousands of games over
and over and over again so a large
quantity of data with which to train the
artificial neural network
what would be the problem with that set
of data even though it's very large why
would it not be very good at training
the neural network
exactly right it'll be really good at
recognizing the kinds of moves i do my
strategies it would be very effective at
beating me okay after playing me many
times but someone else comes along who
has a different style of play who just
tries different kinds of things and
it'll be like i've never seen this kind
of thing before i don't know how to
counter these kinds of tactics or
strategies
so that's chess
what about when you put it into the
situation of trying to recognize
cancerous slides
how are we going to how we're going to
word it what kind of data do we want
right
random slides
yeah okay i think this is what you're
getting at um this is a helpful word to
use variety or diversity maybe
so you don't just want um a large
quantity of data but you want a um
a lot of them that are very different
from each other okay so
that way if there's a single pattern
which goes underneath all of them you'll
be able to recognize it in each of them
okay
all right now one last thing
these two things are talking about the
slides
this thing here right so we want
specific things specific qualities about
it right but we also want a specific
quality about the results that we're
providing and training the artificial
neural network with
what kind of results do we want
yeah oh that's kind of that's kind of
true
yeah that's right um so i'm including
that under that um just a simple one
correct we want the results to be
accurate right can you imagine training
something
right and you know the cytologist just
made a bunch of errors right and you're
like here here you go neural network
learn off these it's going to learn
erroneous kinds of conclusions and it
will not recognize the right patterns
okay so we want accurate sets of results
okay
so when you put all of these together
okay what's the role of training we want
the artificial neural network to be able
to recognize um
in never before seen
slides that's the important thing okay
this is what difference from an expert
system or anything else underneath
if you've got enough slides right and
they're different enough to each other
and you know whether they're
cancerous or pre-cancerous or not okay
then hopefully that'll all come together
and you'll be able to recognize even in
slides you've never seen before okay
just like human beings um whether it's
positive or negative does that make
sense
okay so these three things here really
really important and not many people
mentioned like
usually i just got one someone said yeah
lots of data okay um that was an easy
one but you missed out these other two
okay
right
puppet
critically analyze the responsibility of
those involved in decision making with
pap net okay so critically analyzed what
does analyze mean analyze
what's the key word
not not ipt analyze i mean hsc analyze
okay so this lack of answer is why we
did so badly at this question okay
analyze means to draw out
um relationships and implications
draw out relationships and implications
so you can see actually even though it's
hsc analyzed and not ipt analyzed
they're not that different you want to
get some meaning out of something which
is you know
kind of raw data okay so draw out
relationships and implications
right now uh relationships and
implications about what
about the responsibility of those
involved in decision making
okay so
let's start with the easiest answer
which got you one mark okay um what is
the most obvious kind of situation that
there's responsibility in
decision-making with if you get it wrong
yeah that's right okay uh whether
so this is this is my first point okay
it's about the accuracy of the results
that are developed by
the artificial neural network okay
okay
now who does the responsibility
ultimately rest on
ultimately
now i guess it'd be someone who's got
some kind of managerial or like um you
know medical responsibility over you
know these kinds of um these labs that
are they're conducting all of these
tests okay
and so because the accuracy of the
artificial neural network right it's not
guaranteed okay even if it was a human
it's not guaranteed okay
um this has to be checked
it ought to be checked by this person
this manager or the cytologist or the
lab technicians or whoever
okay people smile because they're like
it's and anyway um so
this is part r like if i'm responsible
for something i want to check it yeah
like i'm not just going to let it
through without and just say yeah it
should be fine okay my name is going on
these results right i'm the doctor or
the technician or whoever who's
certifying yes i think you do have
pre-cancerous cells or i think you are
clear right so before it runs off i'm
going to want to check it even if i
don't check every single one
i should at least check it regularly
right
to make sure it's still providing
accurate results okay and that's
something i need to do with an
artificial neural network that i don't
necessarily have to do with an expert
system
why
why might i have to keep on checking the
system if it's an artificial neural
network
yeah yeah let's try it this is kind of
like the good cache this is kind of like
the benefit of artificial neural
networks right that it's going to learn
and adapt and update but
you got to be careful with it as well
right because if it changes for whatever
reason what if the results are no longer
accurate so that's why i want to go back
to it maybe every week every month
something like that and make sure that
i'm going to manually sit down and check
these results myself okay does that make
sense
okay now this was the the big main point
okay but there were a couple of other
sub points that i was looking for to
show that you are
critically analyzed okay so
what other kinds of decisions get to be
made here things like the um the
security or the privacy of the data
this kind of thing gets decided by the
people who are running the system right
so all this data comes in
how's it going to be used right and as a
patient i want to know that this diet is
being used only for the purposes of
checking out whether i have these cancer
cells or not okay
and so you know not only is the security
or privacy of the data something that
has to be protected but also the purpose
of the data
it has to be preserved
and by the way this is a nice easy one i
think almost everyone missed it but can
you please make note put like bold red
highlight whatever because think about
it this way whenever you've got
responsibility okay and there's the
collection of data there's always the
possibility to use the data for a
purpose that it wasn't intended for okay
so you order stuff online from amazon
right and you have to provide them with
your address
but you assume you that they'll use that
address for what purpose
to ship stuff to you right um if they
want to say send you promotional
material they have to ask you right that
purpose there you know you have to tick
or untick a box that says yes i'd like
to receive catalogs or something like
that okay and often it's automatically
ticked so if you want to get rid of it
you've got to uncheck it yourself
um but if you provide data
like to to this system right you want to
know it's being used for this purpose
and not some other one okay like it's
not being used for someone's phd or
something like that does that make sense
okay so this is what i was looking for
you see all of these come under the
responsibility of whoever's running the
system
right